if you aren't the chess player what
would your profession be and why
if I wasn't a chess player I'd probably
be some kind of engineer yeah it's a
very tricky question because I mean I've
been involved in chess since my uh yeah
very childhood and you know I haven't
really considered like different things
I guess I will just run family business
but not for printers it is really very
unfair to
to think what I could have done instead
because from a very early
stages
I I've sort of missed out on the rest of
it I could say so whatever Hobbies or
interests I have now
it isn't doesn't necessarily mean that
this is what I would be doing right
because from from your early age it
takes certain direction and yeah I just
really cannot tell and
I'll be curious to know because I think
there are lots of things that couldn't
interest me but yeah in my childhood and
later on as well nothing came close to
chess I guess yeah it would be something
um
maybe science related or something like
that it's hard to say exactly but I'm
good that
mad and the computer so those are my two
favorite subjects but I'm originally
born from the Philippines so if I wasn't
a professional chess player maybe I
wouldn't be living in the US right now
because that's how I got in that's why
I'm trying to play good chess so if I'm
not retiring it
um yeah that's a great question
I would love to do a bunch of things but
I guess I would have zero time for any
of those things
so yeah we would be
we will be in a pickle yeah I guess I
don't know I mean you know the thing is
that I'm always hoping to stop being a
professional just player and then and
start out a career so I guess I would I
would need to answer this question
eventually so we'll see
I would be doing something which is uh
connected with stats because I'm uh I
really like stats like a fantasy or uh
some I know something which is connected
with uh sports like football so I think
this one would be something I would
follow I think something competitive
probably you know in a maybe in full of
sports or in the field of art but I
would you know I would love to put my
energy into creating something
I think I will do some science
or let's say I have very good ability to
percolate hundreds and thousands in just
in mind because my granddad is
math teacher so I have this kind of
talent so I probably would be like that
every day
no
um truthfully I have I don't know like
because I have obvious but
I honestly don't see myself
as anything else I will just player but
we'll find out in the future when I
get pushed away by by some young kids
foreign
[Music]